not under a penis oh all right now so
Valentine's Day is almost here and since
I love reading foods and love making
people angry on the internet yeah I'm
gonna rape his box of assorted
chocolates from best to worst but here's
the catch I have no frickin clue what's
inside each of these so yeah until I
take a bite so we're gonna figure that
out together so this is basically a
blind taste test and if you don't like
my opinions then it's fine you're wrong
it's good I'm gonna put the best over
here on the right side and it's gonna go
to like the note and so here we go whoa
okay I'm gonna go for I'm always looking
for the caramel and I never know which
one that is
but let's see that's delicious
that's like a new bit of some sort I
think and that's so far the best I mean
everyone tried one but I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna like that one
let's try this one I love my job I don't
love my job
that's a cherry I mean the whole thing
that's my favorite not caramel I can't
write anymore I'm rating that it's my
favorite I'm not putting on the table
because it's a waste of a damn good
candy okay let's try this one that's
hard
oh my god
I like it though caramel oh my gosh Oh
God beep boop
oh wait check out some kind of nut
caramel is good you know what though
that's like a Butterfinger I remember
you slug butter beans a little but they
get stuck in your teeth so that's gonna
go right here cuz I don't want to go me
picking that out all night okay let's
try this one I should need a minute no
no it's like a weird iCub is that like a
map BAM I want to eat that nope
oh my god oh whoa what are you like Oh
have that broke apart I knew of coconut
yeah I'm in the coconut no oh my god
could you coffee well I don't know what
that is in a nut under a penis Oh
[Music]
they should come out with chocolate ones
that are just like the ones people lack
just saying hey nobody like that well
thanks for hanging out with me I've
never received a box of chocolates
probably don't send them to me either
because I'm not most of them but they're
really pretty and it's very nice and a
little bit of chocolate goes a long way
with your soul but anyway if you didn't
like how I read it I'm sorry but that's
my experience you can choose your own
adventure like the books we were kids
but anyway these are my favorites and
you know what next time if you want to
write something just tell everybody what
you want you know online like what you
want me to write and I'll read it and
you probably won't like it but I don't
care I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this